you are one of those strange stars that
people kind of get obsessed by and the
internet loves Jeff Goldblum so many
things of yours I've hit the internet
and then just take it off like this
listen I think this was the first one
that became a thing the Jeff Goldblum
crew have you seen that I know I became
aware of that I don't know how they have
a well I think they do print it off and
then you put it on bathroom stall doors
did to do it it's good it's a very good
look as well and then of course because
your name is
Goldblum bloom and people have turned
you into flowers there's there are
literally hundreds of you I've only seen
one I haven't seen any bow okay we'll
have you seen this one there you are to
suffer now I have not seen that one
that's a Twitter with Jeff as a daisy
there you are but this is my favorite
this is Jeff dandelion
there's one picture from Jurassic Park
I've got a sexy sexy shot of mr. gone
boom there is this this has been people
latch onto this pic you know this right
yeah I've seen so this is the this has
been turned into an oil painting
how beautifully it's been turned into a
cartoon complete with Barney this is the
one that people really like they've
taken sam neill when he's kind of
rubbing the dinosaur thing and put him
in there you can get a pair they have a
villain as a video you know so you see
me breathing and he's going on a lady
called Beatrix on a Twitter tweeted sam
neill to say hey are you aware of this
it is excellent to which you replied I
am
it is stomach-churning I love sam neill
I haven't seen hi sam neill I haven't
seen him in years I'd love to run into
him well he's lying on your belly it's
virtual world
good eye for detail see you've got the
tissue tissue under hmm the first ad
camo is like you okay am i yep yep and
I'm good am I not gonna show any pain to
Van Damme and I stood up and then he
takes his glasses off he turns me guys